So now that you've had a fair amount of
practice with the distributive property,
I'm going to give you a challenge problem.
In fact, I'm going to officially declare
that this is a challenge problem by
writing challenge and I'll give you a few
exclamation points just to reinforce my
point that I think this is really hard.
Here's a pretty complicated expression if
I do say so myself. We have x plus 4 minus
3 x times the entire quantity, y plus 5
minus 2x plus 7x to the 2nd, and then
subtract it from all of that, 6y. So, this
is gross and messy but. So, this is gross
and messy but. you have all the tools that
you need to simplify this and make it look
relatively pretty. So take your time,
write everything out on paper, and
seriously, make sure that you don't skip
any steps. Or, at least I know, that when
I did this problem, if I hadn't written
anything down, I would have made a bunch
of mistakes. So, take your time. Good
luck.